[Música]
12 horas de entrenamiento al día seis
días a la semana bajo el sol ibérico en
este campo de entrenamiento militar del
noreste de España a unos 50 soldados
ucranianos de entre 21 y 60 años se
familiarizan desde hace un mes con los
leopard 2 a 4 se trata de tanques más
modernos que los que ya manejan en el
frente
a todos provienen de medios acorazados
mecanizados y eso es importante porque
ha facilitado mucho las cosas Todos
tienen conocimientos de carros de
combate Y eso nos ha ayudado a que
adquieran toda la formación que nosotros
hemos le hemos dado y a que se vayan
para Ucrania con un conocimiento muy
aceptable del carro de combate leopardos
A4 en febrero el presidente del gobierno
español Pedro Sánchez había confirmado
al presidente ucraniano el envío de seis
tanques leopardos y posiblemente de
otros cuatro más adelante
Nuestro objetivo es sincronizar la
entrega de los leopard con la
finalización del entrenamiento de los
soldados ucranianos
Polonia Alemania Suecia y Finlandia
también han prometido entregar pronto
tanques leopardo a Ucrania fin del
entrenamiento este miércoles después
estos soldados ucranianos volverán a
luchar en el frente